catherine deneuve façon les principaux
films que vous avez interprété le
président que j'ai tonelli environ deux
ans après les petits chats ce film de
jacques vila qui n'est jamais sortie qui
était ceinturé et j'avais tourné pendant
l'année scolaire
mais j'avais contenu médiatique parce
que je vais pas un rôle important ce qui
permettait d'aller en classe tout de
même
ensuite je tourne à la fin de l'année
j'ai tourné les portes claquent avec ma
soeur rose dans les ags
et puis j'ai deux mois après environ
j'ai tourné l'homme à femmes avec mel
ferrer et danielle darrieux et puis
ensuite j'ai arrêté je ne tournais et
maintenant vous avez le principal rôle
féminin dans un des sketches de la part
des parisiennes réalisé par marc
allégret oui dans les journaux je vais
on parle énormément de vous on vous
attribue certains points communs avec
certaines actrices de cinéma
qu'en pensez vous il est inévitable que
enfin parlé d'un bain sur un plan plus
tôt un plat générale je ne pense jamais
à part jamais en particulier en général
je trouve que c'est vraiment très
d'injustifié moi je veux pas dire que
j'ai une personnalité propre
extraordinaire enfin je veux dire que
les paires et les actrices auquel vous
pensez ambiance à coquelles dans ma
tribune ressemblance est vraiment très
très près vague n'est que les cubains
s'est ouvert pour réagir justement pour
donner tort à ses journalistes
je pense être aimée dans certains rôles
ou d'abord je pense que à l'écran se
rendra bien compte qu'il est vraiment
absolument aucune ressemblance
si ce n'est peut-être une coiffure plus
ou moins apprêtée mais à part ça je vois
pas la ressemblance qu'on peut ma tribu
avec ses actrices est-ce que vous avez
l'intention de jouer ce qu'on propose
des rôles assez sexy comme ces
comédiennes ont joué déjà
est-ce que vous avez l'intention
systématiquement de refuser pour ne pas
qu'on puisse vous attribue notamment ce
quelconque ou si vous vous estimez que
c'est très bon pour votre personnage de
le faire en se moquant éperdument de ce
qu'on dira que je vous dis
systématiquement non je trouve quand
même partie des rôles sexy on proposera
demain tournage il avec elia kazan rôles
sexy je ferai immédiatement même si je
vais montrer nue
un fils avec elia kazan je le ferai
c'est à dire que vous pourriez je ne
refuserai pas systématiquement s'il le
fallait avec un grand metteur en scène
est ce vraiment le rôle je le ferai mais
sinon je tiens pas spécialement à me
montrer c'est filmé et danseurs dans ce
film puisse convenons-en parisienne quel
personnage interprétez-vous j'interprète
une jeune fille de 18 ans écolier du 16e
paraît pure ou très pur et très
complexée sur un plan sentimental où ce
modèle souvent que la sésamie ce modèle
très souvent et ce n'est pas drôle et
sexy du tout motilium tressage les
aimait tourner avec marc allégret moi
j'aime beaucoup marqué les crèches sont
montrés bien avec lui vous savez qu'elle
a découvert des tas de jeunes gens et
jeunes filles les orgies célèbre oui je
sais et vous ne passez par n'espérez pas
qu'après ce film peut-être que vous
serez s'élèvent tout de suite beaucoup
plus que par les petits journaux ou
parce qu'on peut raconter par les
bobards à ça les journaux on leur dit si
tu es le fils d'autres choses mais enfin
peut-être je sais pas vous avez ainsi
dans les pattes même nom un exploit ne
maîtrise que ce personnage vous plaît
à beaucoup oui beaucoup beaucoup j'avais
le genre de personnage que vous aimez
interpréter oui j'aime beaucoup ce genre
de rôle d'autant plus que la personne
qui l'a écrit me connaît bien et moi je
le connais bien et je dis des choses que
j'ai envie de dire enfin que je dis
naturellement dans la vie donc moi ya
pas de problème ou c'est pas la comédie
c'est pas la comédie et vous avez des
projets immédiats de films non pas du
tout et au théâtre vous n'avez pas de
propositions encore estimé vous savez
j'ai vu des branchements je trouve que
pour le théâtre il fait vraiment du
métier est étonné que j'ai fait deux
films que j'ai jamais pris de cours de
comédie jaulin franchement je crois que
vraiment c'est encore un peu tôt pour le
théâtre mais j'aime bien j'aime beaucoup
et j'espère que nous verrons quand même
très souvent à l'écran et au théâtre car
vous êtes ravissante merci
[Musique]